"Click on the chart to build an isosceles trapezoid
with peaks at (-2, 8) and (-4; -1).
Another peak in (3; 8)
and a base, nine units long,
which is parallel to the x-axis. "
Okay, let's see if we can do it.
We can begin by applying these peaks.
So, (-2; 8).
x is minus two, y is eight.
This is the point there.
The next one is x is -4, y is -1.
x is minus four, y is minus one
and that's nice.
They linked the points for us.
Then we are told (3; 8)
Three, comma eight.
It will be right up here.
Now I think when I click on it,
the program will try to draw rights
between this point and this point,
which is not what we want.
This is a trapeze, an isosceles trapeze.
Actually I want to connect (3; 8)
with this point here, with (-2, 8).
Let's see what happens.
Yes, it's not what I wanted to be.
Let me actually delete that.
I'll wipe out here.
In fact, I will first put this point first.
Then I will bring this,
then I will bring this and finally see
where should I put this.
So let me delete all these.
We move all those in the trash.
We move them all to the trash.
Let me start from the beginning.
I'll begin,
this looks like some kind of bug in the program, but let's see.
Let's hope it still works.
Let's apply (3; 8).
This is this point.
Then we will apply (-2,8).
This is the upper side of the inbred trapeze.
It is good to have given us the length,
the length of this upper side is five.
And now we can put (-4; -1).
This is the point here.
Okay, now it looks like a trapeze.
And now we need a base, nine units long,
parallel to the x axis.
So the base is nine in length
and is parallel to the x axis.
We only have to move to the right with nine units.
One two three four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine units.
And then we just move up.
And it looks as if we got it
isosceles trapezoid.
What is an isosceles trapezoid?
This means that these two countries,
which are not upper or lower,
or which are not the foundations, will be equal to one another.
And we see that this country here is equal to this,
and that this upper side is,
you can look at it in the middle.
This is one of the ways you can view it.
I like this isosceles trapezoid.
Let's check our answer.
Let's make sure we have drawn it correctly.
Yes, we did it well.